so a couple weeks ago i saw this image
on instagram
and i thought to myself it would be an
absolutely perfect opportunity to teach
you guys
how to create and document something
like this on archicad 24
and then take it into twin motion to
export a beautiful render
that's even more incredible than what it
looks like in life
what's going on guys my name's david
thomage welcome back to the channel
this is probably going to be a bit of a
longer video than usual so i'm probably
going to break it up into two parts
so in part one of this tutorial i'm
going to show you exactly
how we can replicate this beautiful
instagram image and take it
to a full pdf document that you can
start using as a design point of view
we're going to be talking about the
ground floor plan how you can set up
your footings
your slabs all your walls and all your
windows as well as an interior design
element of this video and then we're
going to be talking about the elevations
and
the external side of the building once
we have all of our floor plans and our
elevation set up we're going to move it
over
into the layout book and show you
exactly how to export this
as a full pdf so you can utilize it and
share it with anybody that you like the
second part we'll take it into twin
motion
and will actually export and render a
beautiful realistic
render that you can showcase on your
social media or even use it in your
portfolio if you're looking for a brand
new job
okay so we've started by opening up
arcade24
and in my instance we're going to select
the australian standard template and
just go
new profile so i'll drag it over to the
screen that i'm recording
and on the left hand side of the screen
we have the image that we're going to be
trying to replicate
and redesign now that archicad 24 has
opened up the first thing you want to do
is actually save the file
so that it automatically saves and
doesn't cause you any problems
if something does crash for some
instance so what we want to do is go to
file
down to save as and save it
anywhere you want for me i'll probably
save it onto the actual
desktop click save so now that we've
saved it it's going to continuously to
order save if you've set that up
which is by default setup on arcade24
what we're trying to do is replicate
this image here on the left which is a
beautiful
container looking home sitting on the
edge of a cliff
it is a relatively simple design and
relatively quick and easy to model
so this is a video for all levels of
archicad users
so in my personal opinion the best thing
to do here is start
by actually modeling the main body of
what we can see here
and then progressing further on from
there so if we look at this image here
on the left
it has a very thin mono pitch roof going
one degree
backwards it sits on what appears to be
a concrete
floor on two i-beams and it's relatively
self-supported underneath of the rock so
we're gonna start by modeling
the base of the floor moving up the
walls then to the roof and then
modeling all the elements around and
then we'll slowly start to integrate the
furniture as well in part two of this
video the first thing you want to do
is open up the level settings which is
either control or command depending on
your system and pressing the 7.
so this opens up our story settings
which as you can see here we have ground
first and roof
what the first thing you want to do is
insert a floor below and
call it footings because we can see that
we have these i-beams underneath and
they are
technically our footings in this
development they don't need to be three
meters
i think they're probably only about or
180 ubs but we'll go 200 for the
purposes of argument and keeping it easy
the ceiling in this space looks quite
high so this lady's probably about
1.6 1.7 metres tall so at the pinnacle
of that
is probably about three meters so it's
safe to say
that we can keep it as the first the
ground floor to the first floor
is three meters however because we don't
have a first floor in this we can delete
that story so we only have
our footings our ground and our roof
personally i like to uncheck these on
the side to remove them from elevation
views
later on but you can keep them on you
can keep them off
we'll come back to that in a little bit
so you just press
ok and because we've deleted the first
story
it's going to come up with a warning you
just click delete anyway because we're
not really interested in it whatsoever
so as you can see we're already on our
footings level but because we've created
a new
layout we're going to go into our
organizer so clicking this little house
here
going down to show organizer and then
opening up the organizer
and reassessing how we actually
structure
our organizational point of view so for
me it's always
easiest to just drag and drop these and
create a new folder here
we're in sketch design we have all these
views already set up
but personally i'm going to hold shift
i'll do that again hold shift click on
roof
and drag and drop that into sketch
design i'll also rename
all of these to just footings i'll
probably do them in capitals
footings rename delete
ground floor rename
delete roof
plan and if i close this now you'll see
that they've popped up on the right hand
panel in our organizer under sketch
design
again you can structure your template
however you want my personal template is
structured completely differently to
this
but this is the standard template that
you get when you open up archicad
so you can see if we go into ground
floor this up the top right left hand
corner changes the ground floor
we go back to footings it changes
depending on the levels
so we'll start with the footings in this
case and we'll start with just
a relatively simple slab so the slab
actually
sits inside the building itself because
the windows go past
so what we're going to do is create a
slab using the slab tool
the slab can be generic or edit the
spaces and the model preferences later
so we'll start by creating a standard
shipping container size so a standing
shipping container is about six meters
long and about two and a half meters
wide
that's the 20 foot model you can get the
40 foot model as well
it's probably not a standard shipping
container but we're just using that as
the base of our guide
so we'll create that as six meters
by two and a half meters so now that we
have a slab that is
six meters by two and a half meters long
we can press the m
key to bring out our measuring tool and
double check that so that's six by two
and a half meters
and we can start developing everything
over and above that
so we can see the master bedroom is at
the front and then we're guessing that
we have the rest of the
um assuming little hotel style room
overlooking the cliff at the back so
we'd have predominantly our master
bedroom here at the front
our entry probably at the back and our
bathroom in the back corner
so we're going to go back up to the
ground floor level and
that footing will disappear so what i'm
going to do is right click on the
footings and
go show as trace reference so we can see
where we've actually created our slab
then we're going to move over to our
wall tool and make sure that it is on
walls
external layer the next thing we're
going to select is the type of wall
so looking at this it'll probably be
some sort of timber frame structure
where the timber cladding around the
outside
what kind of wall you select is
completely up to you depends what you're
trying to create
so at the bottom you'll see we have a
70mm stud partition or a 90mm stud
partition
personally this would probably be a
120mm stud but because it's simple and
easy we're going to use
the 90mm stud option all we have to do
is really click
hold and if we hold shift we lock it in
at
certain degrees so holding shift locks
in at 90 degrees
go all the way around and we have a
perimeter walls
we have the show all in 3d option here
but we can also right click
go down show all in 3d to see how far
along we've already come
so straight away we've actually designed
a slab we've got some walls happening
and we're slowly
creating this model that we see in front
of us if we click on this
main wall structure already and open up
the settings by clicking
on the settings dialog up here or by
pressing ctrl t
we can see how tall walls are so the
walls are actually linked to the next
story level so they're going to be
immediately three meters if you actually
want to change it
you're going to have to change it to not
linked and then you can change it to two
and a half
three meters whatever you want it
because we are using three meters that
setting doesn't actually matter
so we can exit out of that to cancel
those settings that we messed with
go back into it and then start playing
with the actual materials so the first
one is the outside face which is the
blue line along
the boundary of the walls this is the
actual connection of where it ends so if
we run
one wall you can see the end of it and
the inside
is obviously the inside now because this
is a two-part series
there is two ways to do it we can
actually create this texture here on
arcade 24
or we can just select any random texture
and
utilize the textures material in twin
motion
for me personally i think it's best to
show you guys how to create a texture
from scratch so we can actually
import it and use it properly so we want
to create a timber looking texture
we do have a bunch of woods down here on
the side which is really good
but we'll go from scratch so we'll exit
out of that
we'll go to window we'll go to toolbars
and make sure that attributes is checked
if you have attributes checked
that means you're going to be able to
have this section of the palette open
what we're looking for is this little
brush the brush lets you change all your
materials
so we're going to click on the brush
bring that into the screen that we have
recording
and we'll select wood just to make it
simpler
that is the wood that is currently being
used and we're just going to click new
again i'll drag that over here and i'll
go wood
vertical
vertical gray it doesn't matter what you
call it you can call it anything
you can change all your materials
however you want so we'll just go
duplicate
i'm going to change the surface color
from this brown
to a more gray so about there's fine for
me it's not really that important
because we're not rendering in
archicad we're rendering in twin motion
and then we're going to change
this vertical hatching background now
off the top of my head i can't
remember if there is or isn't but there
is a corrugated
horizontal 10 mil hatch there so we can
use that
for now and then i'll also show you how
to create a vertical hatching
to actually emulate this hatching on
your elevations
if this isn't the correct one you're
looking for we also want to change
this material here to something else so
we just go
browse it'll pop up another window and
we're gonna add a new one for the
purposes of argument i've already got a
million one
different textures saved they're just
googled
seamless texture look for something
similar to that image on
the left hand side and try find
something nice that looks kind of
similar so
that one there is probably pretty good
in my opinion
we just go file save as and just
save that to downloads and go save
so we can close out of google come back
into this textures
if i go to my downloads wherever my
downloads are
downloads find that wood texture open it
up
it'll open up the wood texture here we
go okay and it replaces
that wood texture now i like to keep the
proportions of the original texture that
we've actually used because
that way it doesn't mess with the size
and scale and proportions
so we've changed that we've changed the
spectrum color
this element pen if you're using a black
material you'll probably have to change
the element pen to a different color
because you won't be able to see it
but in this instance it'll have nice
black lines in the elevations which
we'll get to in a minute
so then we just click ok and we've
created a new texture
now because the vertical hatching we've
selected isn't identical to what is
shown on this image on the left we want
to recreate
a better vertical hatch so what we do is
come up to this field section
and select something similar that we're
looking to replicate
so in this instance we're trying to
replicate just some vertical lines
and keeping it very simple and very easy
i think for the purpose of argument we
can select most of these
but go through and select something that
is similar to what you're trying to
create to really make this process as
easy as possible for you guys i think
maybe the heel pattern
at a vertical 45 degree angle is
probably pretty good
so if we go new vertical
timber and we'll say it's 125 millimeter
spacing
for the purposes of argument i'm not
entirely sure if it is but
that's okay we'll probably change this
to
scale with paper model so 125
millimeters
125 millimeters and
0 90 degrees
so now we have 125 millimeter
vertical spacing of timber and to make
sure this pattern changes
so we know exactly what it is we're
going to click and hold
to get rid of those patterns and again
click and hold
to draw some new lines and you can see
at the top now it's recreated a new
vertical timber pattern now before we
close this palette we just want to make
sure we tick all three of these so we
can use it with absolutely everything
that way we don't have to come back into
this palette again we just click ok
go back into our surfaces and re-change
our vertical hatching
so if we change this to vertical timber
125
click ok click on this wall
go back into the dialog settings change
the outside
to vertical grey wood that we
created before and click ok
we'll see that we have that texture that
we imported
from the internet directly applied here
so we can
mix and match it later on in twin motion
we also have a slab down the bottom
which is just a generic slab
we probably don't need it to be anything
it's just going to be concrete so we'll
go user defined
and open up the settings again by
clicking command
t or clicking on that dialog box we can
change the structure of the basic
composition
it probably looks like
150 millimeter thick slab according to
that
and we're just going to tick them all
link them and
change it to concrete if we can so
it's just going to be a concrete
structure we click ok
and then we're going to click on this
corner and drag it all the way
up so it's actually hidden underneath
this wall here because as you can see in
the image
it's recessed into the wall so because
the front part of this building here is
going to be mainly windows and glass
we can see that the pitch of the first
windows on the side
is raking a little bit with that one
degree skillion roof
but the front section of this glass is
entirely flat
so if we go to our window tool select
window
and type in window at the top we're
going to have a variety of all the
different windows that we can select
so if we scroll to the top and just
search the windows which we best think
is going to work for this project
i think trapezoid window 24 will be
absolutely perfect
they are entirely fixed windows so we'll
just go
fixed glass so they can't open they are
just genuinely fixed windows start going
through these settings one by one
to try and actually replicate this
window here so
we know that window is three meters tall
and we also know it's probably about two
meters wide
now we're going to continue to make that
sash in the middle and change the pitch
of
the raking of this top of this window so
we're going to go
through the settings one by one so we
have to change this to by top angle and
total height so it doesn't mess with our
total height over here
now that i'm looking at this it's
probably more so three
three degrees if not more maybe five
degrees
yep i think five degrees probably looks
a bit better on this
representation here so we're going to
change that window to 5 degrees
the lower side of that is going to be 2
8 25 the upper side of that is going to
be 3 meters like we sent it
and then we're going to keep going
through them to find the sash
in the middle so we can use this grid
section here to create sashes
and the easiest way for me is always the
hv grid we only need
one vertical and we only need two
horizontal so
there we go we perfectly have that
section set up
now i don't like the fact that it's
orange so you can immediately override
it by overriding lines and overriding
fills
so going straight to black and perfect
that is completely overwritten
now we click ok and we can actually
center our window to the corner here the
one thing we forgot to do is actually
create this corner glass here
that is more so a silicon joint than
anything else so we'll open up those
settings again
go into the special window settings and
find our cornering in this menu
so custom corner is under fixtures and
settings custom corner 2 we want to
rotate at 90 degrees
and we'll click ok so we've actually
selected the wrong one which we can go
ctrl or command
m click the center to flip that window
across
if we click and select the drag function
we can drag it to the corner by holding
by holding command or alt we can
replicate that window very simply now we
have those two windows created on the
side all we need to create is that last
third window there
so we open up our window tool again and
we're looking for probably just window
24
very standard window that we can
mess with and play with to create the
best replica of that
we can find so
window 24 will go through the settings
just like we did before so we go
fixed glass start at the top to make it
easy
and slowly tick through we don't need to
really change too much of these settings
because they're basically just a very
basic window
all the frames are the same we're going
to change that hv grid again
to 1 and we'll go 3. so we have that
it is going to be 3 meters tall and it's
going to be
2 and a half meters wide because that's
how wide we made
our c container in this instance and the
last thing we
change is our custom corners so both
corners in this instance are 90 degrees
we click ok we place our window
and then we drag it to the end
so i clearly haven't made this the right
size
if i click on my dimension tool
and find out how big we made this
it's only two three including that so
what we'll do is actually extend that
120 mil select these two walls and press
ctrl i to join them again so again
select two walls
control i joins them at the top so we're
still probably not at that perfect
two five but that's okay that'll work
for now
and now we have those three windows
created
and overlapping perfectly if we go back
into our 3d model
they're sitting too high up so all we'll
do is select those three windows
and change this sill height to zero
now you see that we see that concrete
slab underneath
sitting just like it is on this image
here
the only difference is potentially the
window frames are the wrong color
so we'll open up those settings again
because we're only changing the color we
can change them all at once so then
instead of going to corner we're going
to
scroll up to openings and model
attributes now you can see it's all
wood but we want to uniform the window
surfaces and it's just going to be some
sort of black
so it will paint it ivory black it will
change them all instantly
and the glass can stay glass clear fast
for the time being
so we click ok and now we've changed
our windows these black frame industrial
windows
very similar to they have over here and
we're going to continue creating
this interior model so if we move back
to ground floor plan what we can see
is the next real basic principle is the
roof if we move up to roof plan
and do the same thing by going over
showa's trace reference
so to draw our roof all we need to do is
come to
our roof tool select either the flat
roof or the pitched roof in this
instance we're doing a single plane
geometric roof so we're going to select
our pitching point from this side over
here
and we're going to tell it that it's
raking this way
upwards and then all we have to do is
really create a rectangle around
so we've created our rectangle our roof
is created if we go back to 3d
we'll see it is ridiculously high
and it is ridiculously too thick so
we'll just do
five degrees and what we're gonna do
is actually change that the settings and
thickness of this roof because
as you can see on the image to my left
it is very thin in comparison to what we
have drawn here
so it again looks like a concrete roof
so we'll just change
the material of timber to concrete
and we'll change the thickness of that
that looks like a very thin roof i'm
only going to guess
90 mil and we're also going to change
the surface override to concrete same as
that slab
so for some reason that has a hatch on
it and we definitely don't want that so
we're going to
jump ahead a little bit here and go to
surfaces again
find concrete2 which is already selected
this grid
and we're just going to turn that grid
off so we really don't need
anything to really show there so we're
just going to select it as airspace
and click ok now what we have to do is
click on the edge and drag that roof
vertically down as best as we can by
holding shift you can
go along the y-axis select it perfectly
at the edge of that roof
and there we go we've aligned that roof
up to the top of this building
what you'll see is we haven't cut any of
the walls so we're going to select
all the walls and right click
connect trim elements to roof shell
you'll get a little warning
you just click trim and our roof
is created and there we go now we have
our building started to come together
starting to look like this over here
it's potentially a little bit too high
so this lady may not have been 1.6 1.7
metres tall but that's okay
we have the basic elements of what we
see over here
if we scroll back up to our ground floor
plan
it will open up our ground floor plan
and we can see one square window over
here above the kitchen
and one small square window here near
the bedroom
which i'm guessing is either next to the
bedside table or
in the bathroom so if we want to create
that we go into window tools again
open up the window palette and
to reset this window 24 we just click on
another window and then click back on
window 24
and we're back to the basic settings
they look like awning windows in this
instance so we're going to go
top hung windows to give us an awning
and they probably look
1200 by one meter yeah so 1200 by one
meter looks approximately right we're
really guessing because we don't have
any information
but that image there so what we're going
to continue doing
is changing those model attributes same
as we did before
so just tickle them change the window to
ivory black
and click ok now that window is
somewhere about here
and this window is somewhere
about here now those windows
definitely look too big so i'm going to
reduce them in size
to 600 by
800 and this one is too low i reckon
that's only about
500 mil off the seal maybe even lower
400 mil so we're about 400 mil up the
side here
we're going to hold alt or command on
our keyboard
and then we're going to hold ctrl and
alt to duplicate those settings and
replicate them
for those two windows and we're just
going to move that one up
to one meter because the kitchen bench
is
normally 900 mil putting it 100 ml above
that kitchen bench is probably
about accurate so now if we go back into
our footings layer
we can still see our building as a trace
reference over the top
we'll go to our beam tool and open up
the beam settings
so we know what we're doing here if we
go down into segment we automatically
have
the setting to create it into a u-beam
and then we can scroll through these
million and one options
to find what our beams might look like
so in this instance this ipe
240 is probably the best option we have
at the moment and it automatically
changes that shape to the ub we're also
going to change the materials to some
sort of metal
it doesn't really matter what we do it's
probably steel
so it's gone to a dark grey it's 240
tall
by 120 wide which is probably perfect
for what we're looking for
and we're just gonna simply draw two
beams
running this way and now we can copy
this by going
to the drag tool and then pressing
control to hit the plus
and moving that further here we'll
probably be a little bit more pedantic
about it
and move that 500 millimeters from the
edge
and do the same with that one
so now we've moved our i-beams 500 mils
from the edge
they are still floating in thin air but
what we'll do
is just select them go ctrl d
move them up and run them underneath the
building
500 mil was probably a bit of an
overkill so i'll move them back
200 mil to each side something that's
starting to resemble this a lot better
what you'll see is also a connection
base underneath which is a simple beam
it isn't as complex as this so we'll go
back into our beam tool
and we'll just go a basic square beam
that looks
like a 90 by 90 piece of
steel that is orange for some reason but
we'll keep it as generic steel in our
model
it does look like this building is
actually cantilevering a little bit so
maybe we push
this beam back 200 mil click on this
select the stretch tool and move that
back
in line so now that our building will
cantilever over a little bit
we'll do the same on this side by
holding shift you can
and then pressing the d function you can
change these
settings so if we have the stretch tool
activated
you'll see that as we move it back the
distance remains
the overall distance but the second you
hold shift
is when it changes so not holding shift
four thousand five thousand holding
shift
one meter a couple hundred depending how
far you are from this
so by holding shift moving back pressing
the d
key at the same time i can let go of
shift and d
type in 200 and we have our
overall beams moved back 200 from the
edge
with this beam here what i want to do is
click on the outside
and select this multiply tool the
multiply tool is super handy and it's
very easy to use
in this instance i want to distribute so
i want to click here once and click here
a second time
and create i don't know this six meters
probably let's say five of these beams
that are one meter spacing so we click
here once
and we click there a second time they're
all copied they're all replicated
so if we go back down to our 3d model
you can see we've created that
framework by holding shift and clicking
on all of these
we can select them at the same time and
then pressing ctrl and d
we can move them to the top of these
beams
now as you can see they're probably not
connected to these beams at all
they would most likely be welded direct
fixed to here
so the easiest way to do that is just to
stretch them to the center
and then personally i'd just delete
these and repeat the steps we just did
so offset multiply i distribute
five copies okay stretch drag
done if we go back to our 3ds they'll be
pushed to the edges they'll be welded
direct fixed there which is something
that you can note
later on but overall we have the shell
of our building completed
okay so now from a design point of view
we probably want to do something in the
interior
so we're just going to go to the ground
floor again we need to have some sort of
entry so we'll go
door door open up the panel settings
the first thing we want to do is just go
back to the top
we can change the size of the door the
styler door everything in here by going
through
so this will probably be a full glass
door
because everything else is glass in this
instance
we can click on this little square door
here to give us
all of the framing widths and sizes
so we'll just go 50 mil 50mm 50mm
and it'll give us a really nice clean
thin framed door all we have to change
there is the model attribute
same as we did before so there it is
paint ivory black
the glass can stay the same and the
floor plan
will tick those change it to black
perfect
so now we can install our door here 900
wide is a relatively good sized door
and we can begin understanding what this
floor plan
could look like so internal walls will
change our
layer from walls external to walls
internal
we'll change our stud partitioning
doesn't really matter most internal
walls would still be 90 ml but we can
change it to 70 for the purposes of
argument
drag that over here because i believe
just the edge of that two meters and
there's our bathroom constructed
what you'd like to do and make sure is
that you have enough distance to walk
so 950ml is probably a little bit tight
i'd personally like it at
1100 selecting those two again we can go
ctrl
i to merge them quickly
and then we don't need that dimension
anymore so we can delete it we have our
bathroom here
so we also need a door we don't want a
grid it'll be
a very solid door because it's your
bathroom you don't really need to see
inside
and we'll change the width of that door
to
800 mil so it's a much smaller door
and then if we just drop our little door
here
we don't need any of this custom text so
if we go back into our settings
now if we go into tags and labeling on
the side here
we can discard that custom text so if we
click the floor plan
you'll see that that changes the custom
text
the leaf width dimension is probably not
correct but
for the purposes of this it doesn't
really matter we'll keep it at 744
and now we have our bathroom created
it'll be a very small it'll be a very
tight bathroom
but we'll play with that in a second and
make that work really well
as you can see there's a bed here that's
pushed right up against this wall
and there is some sort of bookcase in
the middle
separating the kitchen and the main
viewing deck now this building is
probably a little bit tight a little bit
constrained so we might have to move
these
around a little bit to make them work
but we will work together
to make this building look exactly like
this so i think
to understand the rest of the space we
really need to understand if this
bathroom will work
so let's start by adding a couple
objects so we'll go to the objects
change the object layer from landscaping
to mep plug plumbing
and then we're just going to look for a
toilet object
the toilet objects could come up as a
different name for you so wc24 for me
and i don't like that it's purple so we
override everything
and just make it simple black so that
gets rid of that
so we're going to drop our toilet in
we're not going to really worry about
where it is at the moment we're going to
copy it across
we're going to open up our settings
again put in a shower
look for a perfect shower object so we
have our shower
cabin that is a very basic object
it's good for size 800 by 800 is a very
very small shower
but we'll see what we can fit we'll
maybe make it a little bit bigger
and we'll copy that across the last
thing we need in our bathroom
is a hand basin so a simple hand basin
for the purposes
of this design we can change those
settings again to make that
nice and black and we'll probably pick a
rectangular hand basin because that's a
bit old and
ugly now depending on the type of shower
that you use it could be a screen door
it could be a curtain rail
it could be all sorts of different
designs so it really depends what you're
planning on using
but because it is such a small space
we'll assume it is a curtain rail so
there's no doors swinging there's no
doors whacking you can kind of just
enter it freely from any side
we want to rotate the shower and the
easiest way to do that is ctrl
e or you can click on one of the black
dots
and select the rotate tool by holding
shift again
we can do that 90 degree rotation
and then control m allows us to
flip it and mirror it 90 degrees
so ctrl d to move that toilet out of the
way control d
to move that shower in to this space
here
control e lets us flip the vanity
move it across to here and as you can
see already this is a very very
tight space and this isn't going to work
so that's why it's always good to
understand
the spacing and sizing of everything
now in my personal opinion this just
won't work it's not going to work no
matter how much you move it how much you
shuffle it
and if you are designing it from scratch
you want to make it a bit wider
so personally what i would actually do
is drag this wall
at least another 500 millimeters
if not even more to make this bathroom
significantly larger connecting all
these walls by
pressing ctrl i and then simply
extending this window by holding
the move node and connecting it to the
new
edge so now that's three meters wide we
have a much larger space for this
bathroom
we can move this across and we can
actually put our toilet
next to our shower so we'll move the
vanity to the middle now unfortunately
we'll have to go back to our footings
layer
and readjust our footings so the easiest
way
is simply by starting with the slab
extending it across and moving that 500
millimeters
selecting all of our beams in the middle
and dragging them 500 millimeters down
there is alternative ways to do this but
this
for the time being is just the quickest
and simplest way to show you guys
so now we move back to our ground floor
plan and
that is our roof that we also have to
extend 500 millimeters
and we have our main space created
so now this because this is a bathroom
we want to show some tiles we'll go to
the fill tool
we have to change this across to our
very first option to be able to get
a lot more options this is a 300 by 300
tile 250 by 250
400 by 600 so 300 by 300 is a good
example
click and drag and there we go we're
showcasing that as tiles
now the next thing we want to do is
create this little kitchen
over here so what we'll probably do is
just simply extend that wall
across a little bit further and again
we're going to need more space to
actually create that kitchen
because we only have one meter here if
we put
a 600 deep kitchen in it means we're
only going to have 400 millimeters
to walk past and squeeze past our
kitchen
so very similar to how we drag that out
500ml we're going to do the exact same
on this side
so now we have a lot more space on this
side
which means we can also most likely put
that bookshelf
in there instead of a wall so we'll get
rid of that wall back there
and we'll start creating our kitchen so
the easiest way to create a kitchen
is using an object we'll come into
objects so
we have a number of different kitchen
elements in arcad 24 that you can choose
from it's probably just going to be a
very very simple kitchen
so we're just going to select that
kitchen there which isn't anything fancy
it's just the three cabinet kitchen
with a sink in the middle apply our
kitchen to the edge
there now personally if we look at the
3d again
we'll see a couple things that have gone
wrong
these two walls are over the top of the
roof so we're going to trim them to the
roof again
similar to how we did the exterior we're
going to come to our explore man
drag the kitchen and the window
up a little bit in line with
that slab because we actually created
that slab wrong
and overall we're probably not too far
from the look of that kitchen there so
for the time being we can just keep it
as is
if we go back to our ground floor plan
we have our main kitchen
we have our bedroom but we don't have a
bed so we're going to create a new
object
and just type in bed and
pop in any random bed for the time being
use the rotate tool
to rotate it how we want push it down
and there we go we have our first bed i
would actually
be tempted to say that bed goes
that way perfectly along that wall
and then we'll import that bookshelf in
twin motion
now really all we have to do is put a
couple bits of text in
and showcase the elevations of this
building as well
so for the text it's very simple you go
to the text tool
tap anywhere type in bath
and change it to black
so we want to center that text 200
millimeters
and put our bath here copy it across
bed copy it across
kitchen and lastly we'll call this
the lounge for the purposes of this
design
and there we go our ground floor plan is
completed
now i just want to take a quick little
break here and a quick pause
to mention something very exciting on
this channel this channel has been
growing
phenomenally well over the past couple
months as i'm producing more and more
architecture content and you guys are
loving it so thank you
so much for being a part of this
community and helping this channel grow
because of all of your support i've been
able to reach out to one of my premium
brands that i love working with so if
you look at my past
12 months of videos if not even longer
you'll notice that i'm always wearing a
black shirt
and most of the time if not 99 of the
time it's
more than likely a cut shirt i've been
wearing cuts for
a good year and they've genuinely been
the best shirts i've ever purchased in
my life
so i decided to reach out to them and
see if they were willing to partner up
on this channel
to be able to help me produce better and
better content every day so if you're in
the market for the highest quality
shirts in the game
that are just so buttery and soft and
smooth
and the second you put them on you know
they are absolute premium quality
there's a link down in the description
below if you don't want to or you're not
in the market
that's absolutely okay i just genuinely
appreciate you guys
being on this channel learning and
producing better architecture
okay so i've just recorded this section
twice
and both times there's been an error
with my phone
so i'm re-recording this section for the
third time and hopefully
this works without a glitch basically at
this point in time
we are setting up some elevations and
taking our completed ground floor plan
and elevation designs
into a layout book to export it as a pdf
you'll see that i've already dragged
these four elevation markers
across closer to my building and changed
the color of them
so all i've actually had to do to change
the color of them is select them all
click on the elevation dialog settings
go into marker
uniform pen color and change that to
black or whatever color you want
personally i like to set them up similar
to this style
very close to the building and they are
named appropriately e1 e2 e3 e4
all of those correspond with the
elevations under the sketch design
sketch design elevation sections here so
elevation one if we click on it will
showcase
the building from this side to this side
three
that side and so on so if we click on
elevation one for example it would open
up
that side of the building looking away
from the rocks the first thing we want
to do is
take a polyline tool change it to green
because that's my color of
preference for the ground level and get
away from the arrowhead
we want to start drawing a natural
ground level that somewhat resembles
what we see in the image
so what we've drawn here is a simple
green line just stopping before the edge
of the building
and it falls away indicating the rock
levels
and then the water level down below ngl
in australia stands for natural ground
level
this could mean a number of different
things in your region in your zone so
call that whatever it needs to be called
but for the purpose of this it's just
simply ngl
the other thing that we can do on an
elevation at a very early sketch design
stage
is just showcase a couple annotations of
what is going
on in this the wiki for example show an
arrow from here
to this cladding saying timber cladding
from here to this window
saying window and another one to the
roof saying
roof at five degrees so just as simple
as that all we had to do was really
draw a polyline change the color to
black
select an arrow and draw our arrow
as required and put some text over the
top
so changing it to black
that's exactly how we created all of
those annotations there on the side
so all we have to really do now is
replicate it throughout the elevations
because i am recording this for the
third time we'll jump through these
elevations and i'll just talk you
through
why i did exactly what i did
elevation two looks at the rear side
from the natural ground level and you
wouldn't see the cliff or any of the
water
so all we've had to do is draw one green
line underneath
those beams which i've annotated steel
beams as per engineers documents because
it's very early in the design
and annotator door so there's nothing
really complex happening here the only
difference is there is no
water level on this side because it
would be beyond
in the distance elevation three looks at
the complete opposite side of elevation
one
so we've literally just copied and
pasted this green line and mirrored
across
to create an identical ground floor
of the other side and just again copied
and pasted
those annotations across finally
elevation 4 looks at the front of the
building
which is what we see in that amazing
image and it's literally you're looking
at the ground
and you're looking at the water if you
were to look at it dead on
so all we've done in this is draw two
green lines one for the natural ground
level
one for the water level just very
generally assuming where the water level
could be because we have no information
from the surveyor
we have no actual realistic information
on this project
we're basically just making it up to see
if we can replicate what we see
on instagram now that those four
elevations have been completed we want
to
export it to a pdf so we can actually
take that project to somebody
and show them what we've actually done
or even send it to them in an email
so we want to move across to our layout
book and you'll see there is a number of
different
options in the layout books i personally
don't like their layouts
they're just too confusing too complex
there's too many stages in all sorts of
bits and pieces
so i always have a tendency to create my
own the easiest way
for this project because it's a very
small project is just to create a
one-page
piece of paper that showcases everything
so we're going to go down to the bottom
create a new layout and call it
cliff home for example it can be called
whatever you want and
change that to an a4 portrait title
block
and click create so with it
automatically creates that a4 title
block page with the print guides so you
don't have to chop anything off when
you're actually printing
i will go into another project of how to
actually create these title blocks what
information you need
but for the purposes of this you can
very quickly and easily just
change any of this information in the
master section so if i double clicked on
that master
project you can actually go through open
the source view
and change all this information
as required so we're not going to go
into that in this video
we're going to close that master section
there and go back to cliff home
so for the cliff home what we need to do
is open our view map
scroll up to the ground floor plan click
and drag
our ground floor onto this layout book
what you'll see is it's dragged quite a
large section
of the layout over and we don't need
that so we're going to use our offset
edges
and bring this back in to a much more
manageable viewing platform and viewing
space
and then click ctrl d to move it into
the center top of our page
i'm very pedantic about title blocks and
everything lining up
so i like to stretch out my title block
so it aligns with the
invisible edges it makes no sense but it
does when you're working in archicad
now we also want to have some sort of
scale bar and north point on this
project
we haven't created one on our ground
floor plan we haven't created one
anywhere
but we can simply open up an object tool
type in
scale to get our first scale bar click
ok
introduce that into the project we'll
move that a little bit further
away from the house and we'll do the
exact same
thing with the north point
now you can use any north point you want
you can annotate it however you want
for the purposes of this project that
one's absolutely fine you have a variety
of different options
we'll change it for the sake of just
changing it and
introduce a new north point here so now
we have
our north point we have our scale bar
and if we go back to our cliff home in
the layout book
we can drag another floor plan across
and find our north point and scale bar
so one additional step that we didn't do
in the last one because we wanted that
title block is
opening up the settings dialog and
simply going to title
linear drawing title no title
that removes and eliminates the title so
when we actually drag this
closer and hide everything else
in this layout we don't have an
additional title for no reason
now you can drag this anywhere you like
in this instance i would probably
take away that north element because
it's not required
now if i was to drag this somewhere i
don't really like that i'd probably
copy and paste that one across hide
the scale bar hide the north point
and then move them individually so
i'd prefer my scale bar here above my
ground floor plan and i'm happy with my
north point there
what i then want to do is highlight all
of my elevations
inside my view map drag my elevations
across
let them update which takes a couple
seconds
move them all to a place where i can
see them away from the layout book find
elevation one
drag that onto my sheet of paper find
elevation two
repeat that for all four of these
elevations and then what we want to do
is actually just start
lining some bits and pieces up so we
want to align the natural ground level
with that natural ground level we want
to align the title block
by selecting move sub element with
this title block and we want to align
that title block by clicking the stretch
button with that
imaginary window finally i'll move that
a little bit closer
to that elevation and center it we'll
repeat that exact same process with
these two down here
last but not least we just have to
export this as a pdf
so all we have to do is click that cliff
home and select that page
if we have multiple pages just hold
shift and click on the last page to
select them all
then we want to go to file save as we
need to change it from archicad solo
project to
pdf file and then we want to click on
document options so basically it's going
to come up by default as
entire layout but we want to change it
to selected layouts in navigator only
depending if you want in black or white
or color you can also change that but
i'll keep it for color for the time
being
and then literally all you have to do is
press the save button within a matter of
seconds it'll be saved to your desktop
so if we go back to our desktop
open up our pdf we'll see that that pdf
has been exported exactly like we set it
up in archicad
it is a very typical pdf format so you
can use that as you would use
any other pdf you can print it you can
email it you can
copy it you can do whatever you
absolutely like with that pdf anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
the video i hope you learned something
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and as
always
i'll see you next monday